and something strange happens on YouTube
what can you do go to our patreon ah
I'll talk more about that later it Ghost
Busters afterlife the official trailer
is here and the original cast is finally
returning
oh you mean Kristen Wiig and Kate
McKinnon and Melissa McCarthy did you
notice he listed everyone but the black
girl Leslie Jones racist over here
Gustafsson her name
[Music]
somehow the talent isn't anywhere near
tectonic plate music
[Music]
[Music]
the son who's her dad
who's her grandfather
[Music]
my grandfather has to be there or any
Hudson
reason Tracy let's get homework
hahaha wow so different interesting well
I guess ghostbusters is getting the
Amblin entertainment treatment right
that's stranger things popularity in
there so fin wolfhard is just destined
to be typecast kid and paranormal
situation with and wise crack jokes in
the 80's horror genre suppose 80 is a
nostalgic genre at least I thought it
was interesting how like the first parts
of this trailer just seemed like a Jason
Reitman film like the Jason Reitman
indie dramedy vibe this coming-of-age
story of sorts story about people yeah
and then it transitioned into yeah an
amble entertain Minh film more so than I
even thought it might have even we going
to the woodshed and the car there was it
seems I was like oh it's like that scene
when he discovers ETA we shot it does
reminded me of that sense of like wonder
but also danger here yeah I'm assuming
that the grandfather has to be the
Herold Raimi's character the Spangler
character which I think would probably
the most appropriate way to handle the
situation considering that he's the
original Ghostbuster who unfortunately
passed away that way you still have his
presence be talked about and be alive
and he was the smartest of them also
liked the idea of bringing back the
original cast without him didn't feel a
little bit odd lot odd I mean he was
such an integrity he was like a
co-writer on it and right to the second
one I think having his presence really
be felt is important and I'm glad that
trailer did not lead with pure nostalgic
purposes like they'd hint at it with the
80s footage when they're looking on
YouTube or something there's a lot to
look forward to here I think I have to
really a jet this isn't this doesn't
feel like the true ghostbusters 3 I
don't think they said Jason stuff I
don't think they've said it but the way
like the marketing has been through
and leading up to the official trailer
has been this is going to be the Real
Ghostbusters back directly to the
efforts link to the original characters
and stuff but it's a whole vibe mood and
every kind of complete yeah it's like a
completely different kind of film I
guess that kind of threw me for a loop
this is one of the things that when you
do reactions that you get a little bit
surprised and it takes a little bit of
time sometimes to process what you're
feeling and thinking I like it I do it
does feel very much though a product
that would happen of the now it feels
very no way we handle our eighties
nostalgia yeah yeah yeah funny because
like in the one sense I'm not blown away
by this trailer in the other sense I do
appreciate that it isn't exactly what I
thought it was gonna be and it wasn't
exactly like remember how the last
ghostbusters went we're just gonna tape
over it with all the stuff that you love
and remember like I like it it does kind
of appear to be doing something that
could be its own thing and it seems
appropriate that Paul Rudd the character
who would have been around during the
80s is the one who's enthused about this
and the kids are just kind of learning
about it they don't have the built-in
knowledge it's not like oh they're
obsessed with Ghostbusters or something
so there will be like that scent of
sense of discovery and if you're
repackaging this for a new generation
again you know that seems appropriate
anyway as much as there are a lot of
debatable circumstances I feel like yeah
I like having the jason reitman tone
especially if you're gonna have the kids
it might be worthwhile to do some kind
of coming of age but there wasn't
anything that made me like ah I can't
wait I think what Ghostbusters will we
tend to associate is the comedy or the
fun spooky stuff yes to which I know a
lot of people care about Ghostbusters
are the same time I'm like those are
elements I think are very important I
like that there's like this whole thing
is Dean Apple and entertainment wondered
this is what it was the whole time yeah
I'm like is this gonna be just like a
coming-of-age story when it goes back
because that would be interesting but I
don't know if that's what everybody
wants I don't know how people are gonna
respond to this trailer there was a
slaughter when it came hey Ghostbusters
is a
very fascinating pastime that
errantly even taking that moment from
Bill Murray's odd audio from
ghostbusters 1 when he's you know
convincing dan Aykroyd of like no we
asked our own business call it fate call
the ARMA 2 repurpose that dialogue or a
more wondrous vibe yeah I thought was
really I don't feel like oh wonder there
I felt in them in the first movie it
seems like like yeah he has this like
overblown optimism about what they can
do in their tight situation but he's
still trying to manipulate his friend
yeah doing something so if here in Leo
okay I guess there is a sense of joy
here Ghostbusters 2 that picks up where
the Ghostbusters are has bins there's no
ghost activity ghosts come back and then
there they're back in the spotlight
again and then they they solve a big
problem and then I guess they're just
forgotten and then fade into obscurity
is very like what have you done for me
lately for the Ghostbusters kind of a
weird trailer I got processed I respect
that there's there seems to be like some
horror things but it just seems like
straight out of stranger the scene is
this is to stranger things this to me
it's that thing where things that
inspired newer pop culture mainstays
yeah and get inspired by those things
that they expire it's like when I saw
the the 300 sequel I was like this looks
like just like all the Spartacus shows
that 300 helped open the door yeah this
does very much feel like it's got all
the things we love right now to make
this popular not that it couldn't work
it's gonna be all kids ostensibly like
operating the ecto and things like that
and I'm a little curious about how
that's gonna play - especially after
having people ghostbusting who nobody
could agree on last yeah swooping it out
for kids seems like something of a tall
order for some people I would imagine
maybe butter Jason Reitman it's son if I
Brightman but they're very they've made
very different ability yeah
and so it's cool that jason reitman is
doing more of what jason reitman would
do and i like the cast i like the
director even though i love the first
Ghostbusters I'm not like religious
about it yeah some people say movie
don't you have anything I prefer that
this is uh this is at least looks
different than what I expected
yeah and it'll probably grow me alright
guys well what did you think of the
ghostbusters afterlife trailer do you
like this rendition are you do you think
this is gonna be amazing
I don't know brought ghostbusters back
to its glory make sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell if you
enjoyed our video don't forget to hit
the like button as well make sure to
check us on patreon will reduce stream
along for many shows stream allow me
sync up with the timecode those series
are agents of shield straighting season
3 Gotham Cobra Kai season 2 and then
there are several shows where we
actually do reaction highlights for them
so you can actually get the stream along
option or watch a cut-down version with
reaction highlights footage included and
those shows are supernatural Hunter
hunter code geass Death Note my hero
academia movie included an attack on
titan and i like to end this with a page
of the day shout out to a man named
Derek Mitchell when there's something
strange happened in your car dude who
are you gonna call Derek Mitchell didn't
do you know if I kick something off and
you're just gonna rub me I was gonna say
call an uber Oh call an uber cuz he
could Eric Mitchell is driving for them
a lot of times I set up these things
that I'm about to knock out of the part
and then you just read it with a
completely different comment didn't you
you know Derek I'm sorry sorry Derek for
the way Jon has ruined your shout out
look I'm glad you're back at our patreon
I hope you have a good Christmas and
hopefully as you per and lift the people
will tip you significantly more because
they're in the spirit of the holidays
yeah plus those peak holiday hours and I
hope they don't ruin your shoutout Erik
the way how he has done this year I'm
sorry so much Huber's for me I'm sorry